wow look at those pretty new graphics I
like those do you I do you know what
else I like doing what shooting stuff in
weird fictional Asian countries hello
and welcome to games spots now playing
of Far Cry quad quatro you looking
forward to this very much so it's great
H we played a bunch of this we did a
bunch of hunting um on the site
yesterday in fact we did uh but uh we're
just going to go free balling today mhm
stuff that's your that's your screen
there you're that dude I'm I'm rocket
launcher bro here I got the bandana and
and the killer goat T I can give you
ammo but why would I give you ammo when
all I have is Rockets Rockets your
favorite look how pretty this game is
it's pretty good it looks pretty
freaking good look at that um yeah
you've spent some time with this
honestly how do you how do you feel
about it so far I what the [__] what the
[__] hold that thought we're trying to
talk about G video games
got him wait were you just standing
there stand there so how do I feel well
rolling in the I got to take a
photograph sorry yeah tell me tell me
how you feel I feel um you know having
never played Far Cry 3 I'll be honest oh
wow really yeah I know and um it's for
me it's like a whole new world but I
keep hearing
similarities with the game um to Far Cry
3 uh so some people you
know how do you feel is it oh I love it
I mean I'm trying say absolutely love it
I played uh a good four five hours not
including what we did yesterday so I'd
say you know top that off about seven um
sorry there's a dude shooting me which
is why I'm GTFO here we are not getting
much of a break here pull stuff out of
my arm so I'm currently um yeah how far
this is my save we're in at the
moment you got to go Tim to
die this is my save r at the moment
because I haven't unlocked very much and
we don't want to show stuff too late so
I've done about two hours I think I just
launched you into my blad there I'm
sorry you did no that's
okay if you want to come and uh revive
me or I should I could give up yeah I'll
go get
you where you going um yeah so we don't
want to show too much so we're going to
do a bunch of um Towers a bunch of
outposts M and just basically kind of
show off what's going on in the Gamespot
chat we're in there as well if you have
any requests for stuff we should do by
all means let us know I'm going to say
hello in the chat right now I think I'm
logged into Chris's account but just
send me messages there and um yeah and
we'll get to it hey Rob what's up hey
just you know taking a little breather
this is the new gyro copter mm uh we can
repair this too yeah could you do a
little hot repair there you got it um
yeah this is a really really stupid um
and Brilliant uh vehicle which uh not
only can you uh kind of you can hold on
to the side of it if you want but you
can grapple from it as well which is
which is pretty pretty stupid pretty
great and uh do note that this is uh got
a lot of duck du tape on it yes amazing
duct tape I think we're we're good want
to hop on cool yeah I'm kind of over the
uh the Rope yeah the grappling is
difficult especially when somebody like
me is is driving uh where do you want to
go let's go to looking at the map here
you want to you can want to fly or and I
can pinpoint something let's see um yeah
go to I'm guessing it's showing what I
have unlocked as well so far so let's
just go we can do straight up like
single player missions here right we can
just do like story Miss and stuff even
um I'm actually not sure about that okay
well let's not maybe let's just try and
do location to location actually you
know what I'm going to hit this B Tower
unlocking Towers it's the Ubisoft way in
every single game or unlocking CTS
Towers or farry Towers or boura Towers
there's something about Ubisoft where
they just love climbing [__] and then
breaking a radio at the
end H I wonder if I can just drop you on
top of this one yeah we actually tried
the the other day um jerem and I were
playing where uh via rope like you CU
you can kind of Swing on the um on the
rope and so I swung onto like the awning
of the Tower and then was like slipping
off it was pretty great but yeah you can
do that I wonder if I can cuz all you
have to do on these is climb to the top
like it's exactly like Far Cry 3 like
it's the same oh look there's a rope
here and there's a ladder here and it's
you know it's been a while since the
last one so whatever but um not is it is
that all you have to do like when you
get to the top it's that same just break
the radio shenanigan so I'm I wonder if
we can just totally game this and drop
you off the top yeah should be too hard
um let's skip the uh the game
part let's not earn it at all look at
this pink sniper rifle I have it's
pretty tough did it come did it come
pink or did you well this is actually
not my account so uh I'll use that as an
excuse
okay all right okay wait wait wait let
me just get you a little bit closer I
don't want die I want to break a leg
okay go for it and here we go I also
wonder if like you unlocking it unlocks
it for me or not so I do know that like
whoever hosts oh
no I didn't think I'd slip
off tough tough [__] all right if you oh
did you just respawn on the top just I
just I just Wing suited into the do it
again I want to see you respawn again
okay all right so last last time you
respawned not even on the chopper just
like just in midair all right let's see
what happens this time I think you're
supposed to spawn on us
yeah all right hit X to respawn okay oh
you're on all right wing suit into it do
you have a parachute as well like a
bat here we go wing suit wing
suit
all right I'm going to try I got to hit
my shoot earlier let me get one more try
okay I'm going to go a little bit higher
just to give you some uh good do you
have a parachute automatically you do
you have a parachute oh get away from me
did you uh fill that thing up with what
what's is it breaking milk okay okay oh
if you go too high it freaks out cuz
it's like altitude it's not it's not
great it's a piece of crap here we
go like a
bat he looks looked like shoot oh it's X
that's right all right you got okay here
we go hit that to coming in hot there
can you just go over to the where's the
radio uh there is there I wonder if you
can do it with it unlock for me yeah so
I'm not so there are certain things that
like only the host will no done and done
liberat I am a liar this is I guess
you're in my game so so it happens to my
game cuz aon's account is way further so
aon's probably already done that Tower
presumably oh yeah that's that's very
possible so it's it's just whatever
happens I guess
happens let's go there that looks like
fun uh it's kind of dark Tiger Den
that's what I call my
house the oh wait look now I'm on the
tower all right hey what's up well what
the hell did your chopper go that's kind
of annoying it's a bit annoying I don't
have a wing suit either I have unlock Do
Not Bummer oh you can zip line down yeah
you wing suit can you wing suit then can
you jump straight off the only thing I
will
do wing suit I'm going to
get it's sorry I got you why Slow Down
slow down am I one one and three on the
wing suit Jesus you got a terrible wingy
ratio oh yeah that's what you look like
because of wi no that's how I sleep in
my bed with your with your junk just
hang in there it's very comfortable do
that okay
cool
oh s dude like how did you turn off our
Tower we didn't even see you come in you
piece of [__] whoa is that you guys up
there I should probably not have the the
rocket launcher right now when we're
going to fight people I I should dump
out's where is it God damn it this but
head oh there he is oh he did a slide
nice move that a qu bike oh come on oh
there he is okay I got him I got him
don't worry what's up I'm blowing it
right now
done what else we got oh look at this
but head
where is he oh come on tag him up
oh all
right where the shot god damn it got him
oh that would suck so much get an arrow
in your
neck is there is he got a gun I'm going
to take his gun I don't need this rocket
launcher
anymore got no we ammo anyway All Right
Moving On Moving
onwards you want to go to where those
dead bodies
were that looked like fun sadish sad
room what called like s sad room sure
sure it sounds like the place oh there's
a car over here is that like I bet I can
run there faster you try you try to do
it I bet I can R there faster hey guys
what's up oh no you're part of my you're
my crew you're the orange guys you're
the game
spotters um damn it it's like we're like
tourists and we've come to creat and
we're like you I've heard of this place
on Yelp say this is sad room should we
go there I've heard it's I've heard it's
to die
for oh look at this review oh you you're
doing auto drive at the moment which me
you're probably going to run me over
yeah you're
right Auto Drive is a new feature where
it's pretty cool I actually like it if
you get bored you know you don't want to
drive can you handle the acceleration
though can't you yeah so you can control
acceleration and kind of oh I just
bailed they're more they're more
involved with this Eagle I got to knife
this guy oh they're Sho with my
gun knife Dam keep throwing away my
knives I wonder if the loot is shared
yeah this looks like the
place where's the room though oh let's
go in uhoh this is like fall out is
there another Eagle just going to I saw
the shadow oh what's he doing he's
flying okay I can't wait for us to be
finished here so I can have go I really
want to kill him with bow on this sick
uh yeah I can do it
come on baby no you know how hard it is
to kill these things with an
AK-47 this is hard this
hard there's two of them I beef that one
here we go this is it this is it I can
feel
it ah I'm like trying
to no all right stop angering the Eagles
let's go into the side room one more
shot there's not a million years you
hitting that never I really want to I
can't take it out with a gun come on all
right I'm wasting everyone's
time damn it
all right oo this looks promising
danger you know we need a danger sign
when there's a bunch of dead bodies
outside the
cave that's the first indication do not
go in look at all these all these
ominous looking doctors equipment this
reminds me where I grew
up see what's in here tiny booze tiny
booze what's the weirdest thing you've
picked up uh I picked up
uh maxi pad yeah I keep finding maxi
pads maxi pad um forward city of pain
you've been doing fantastic work here
buddy really Stellar results as you know
I'm going to be leaving Crow for weeks
blah blah blah blah blah going to be
throwing a get together in the city of
pain I don't want
to is that like a house of pain House of
Pain is that like House of P is that
where House of painer from House of
House of tame I thought that was
Boston where's the way out of here where
did we come in this getting weird what
the hell are we supposed to do in here
that's it read read a little note wait
did we get locked in booze no we're back
out here oh no we keep going up here
this is just a little hangout that's the
lobby
area pick these mushrooms up they're
probably good mushrooms want shroom want
to go to Shangri La Shang La have you
done any of the Shangri La levels no I
have
not um that's the room we were in does
it keep
going well look at it there's like a
mask in here how do we get in here
what's this life balance is gone there
is no balance bansur has rained for too
long now is the time of Yong the
goat game's got a great narrative you're
tell me a goat wrote
that wait there's a mask in
here I know that's a collectible oh
really yeah I I picked one up in the
bottom of the lake
on but it looks like we can't get it so
that's fun there must be a way
in
H all right up here oh here way like
this looks like a dead end wish had like
a flashlight there's so much there's not
enough gamma Happening Here what if we
jump down here is this the way we came
yeah I think that's the lobby area all
right let's get out of here this is
tedious and boring yeah it
is there's probably something worth
looking at in here but yeah I wonder if
it's also like a progression thing like
maybe you get a key to open that up I
don't know jeez all right you do that
I'm going to take this thing later a oh
wait if I kill myself I actually spawn
with one oh really yeah so uh I love
this world of Far Cry 4 kill myself kill
yourself actually I'm going to ATV it
off I got to check my map while I'm
doing that thought I go to pin's
house proin just lives down here there's
C right
there so my short enough time I three
hours or so of playing Far Cry 4 it's uh
yeah like you were alluding to earlier
um it's Far Cry 3 in a different place
and I'm I'm okay with that oh look it
I'm in my own oh I see it's uh I timed
out because I was too far away from you
cool I can't I can't be away from you
Danny I love you so much it's um
basically the same type of progression
of like uh unlocking Towers which
unlock these sort of
uh interest points you can remove
posters which is always cool very fun
save those um yeah and you're just there
are the story beats which kind of
progress the The Wider uh
map so there's a whole other area to the
north of here which gets unlocked at a
certain stage which I cannot access at
the moment and we don't want to show too
far into this game a lot of dead
people H yeah but it's it's it's lots of
fun and it's you know it's it definitely
is more concerned in keeping you
entertained while you're playing than
actually being in any way difficult all
what the hell does it
say heed this lesson some of this house
stuff is just like nonsense I think yeah
just it's another propaganda thing so
let's actually do a mission or like
liberate an appost or something yeah and
there's like survival um we were trying
to find the other day hopefully we can
find it there's like a survival um kind
of like mini game where like you
basically survive waves of honey badger
oh yeah and defend uh civilians and it
was a riot we were we were using like C4
to like blow them to bivion uh I'm going
to look for an outpost because that's
sort of the yeah Outpost are that's
great well they are the the tried and
tested farry 3 progression thing just so
people can get a look at them right what
did the farry what did they even look
like
anymore there so many things Pagan's
wrath Fortress I am getting shot
at ourselves a uh truck is that one
there all right I might have found one
there I can't tell what's this oh no is
that one there all right I'm pretty sure
this is one here cool okay what's right
get in the truck you drive
okay here we go punch it punch it oh
hear that shot that was me I shot it oh
there's a sharper you can trade with
them or shoot them you can kill them
yeah kill them kill anyone
no yes a oh he's an innocent civilian
what a shame all right get us there you
got it let's do it auto
drive H so Auto Drive will let you shoot
as well well actually it's now I haven't
seen this before it's it's simply taking
me to the wayp point yeah if you set a
waypoint a new Auto Drive it'll it'll do
that if you're already on a road it'll
just drive on the sort of path of least
resistance on that road H but you can
shoot as well if you're on Auto Drive do
you have a pistol uh uh show the folks
at home hit the left trigger you just
shot that oh my pistol is a freaking uh
grenade launcher great so hit the left
trigger hey yeah so you can you can
basically just uh use that I I guess as
your my pistol is just this little
scorpion thing uh which is cool so you
can drive yourself and do it as well if
you want um kind of glitched out here
but uh you don't uh you don't have the
same freedom of control as if you stick
it on the auto drive thing which is cool
because there a bunch of sometimes you
get caught up in kind of um those Chase
sequences that were happen quite a bit
in Far Cry 3 all right let's not drive
straight into the
face [__] run me over back
up all right how do you want to take
this you've already set the alarm off so
we do the next one I didn't the car did
I'm driving next time do you want to
take it in the left want take it in the
right yeah I'll take oh God I'm getting
already screwed up
here oh do we have any meat let's throw
some meat in there let's distraction I'm
doing
it so the meat if you don't know again
staple far c 3 mechanic uh will bring
some sort of uh animal Into The Fray
usually a oh [__] usually a tiger which
is running right towards me thanks can I
use this nope kind of blowing it here
huh the [__] is he gone look at this oh
get I think I killed him he went too
close to that
no all right well oh there's a there's
an elephant over there thankfully one of
the skills I have upgraded is my ability
to ride elephants
so hopefully I can kill that line with
this sweet
elephant oh [__] [__] I jumped off come
back get back on save me with an
elephant oh I will they stop trying to
kill me with
die
whoa watch this ready do it oh no I shot
a grenade I got he exploded like guts
and everything watch him watch me run
over this dude with an elephant elephant
move
upstairs [__] this I'll just shoot him I
believe it's pronounced
elephant all right there's a truck at
the end of the road this elephant's
going
to take it the [__] out we're doing all
right bow
arrow you did it the blue flash means we
killed everyone I thought I died for a
second
all
right and one of our blue trucks is
already arriving perfect okay let's Mom
and Dad are here stealth the next one
cuz that was actually really small
Outpost as well that wasn't exactly that
was that wasuh evocative of can I get a
hey baby hey baby can I get up on
here that's a one seater huh even though
it's clearly more than that this Elin
can't handle it I guess in which case I
will drive oh I want this car
k a Manor can we even go there
sure third car this week oh there's one
right
here I think this one's bigger let's go
to this one let's do it Keta Manor all
right you drive I'm going to take this
sweet elephant
oh that I wonder how fast my elephant
can
go ooh traction is a little
weird this is like an episode of Top
Gear where one of them drives and one of
them rides an
elephants which episode was that love
that one run I wonder if this guy will
like start freaking out a fight like Red
Dead Redemption style if I keep I just
block the road that's all I'll just
block the godamn road funny want get
past oh yeah go past go past there no no
hey [__] nope get off the road bet do
you have insurance for that ele this is
the elephant
Lane oh look there's another elephant
hop on that elephant can you ride
elephants oh I better
I I have to right I hope
uh do it before I Molotov your elephant
damn right yeah throwing a knife at him
smells like elephant all right let's do
it okay let's stop stop stop stop there
for a second sure in line three 2 one
go imagine seeing this oh oh [__] what
the [__] happened whoa they both di what
the [__]
what [__] the compet oh no the
competition just became too much for
them oh no I what well all right let's
save this get the bo let's not let
anything go to waste what the [__] was
that oh man uh pretty Tony in the chat's
asking does it feel as big as three
bigger or bigger how does the frame rate
how's the frame rate been frame rate's
been fine for me it's fine looks super
sharp we're playing on PlayStation 4 um
it looks better on PC as you might
imagine but um yeah it's been great um
I've had no problems with that in terms
of scale I don't actually know but there
has been no talk around the office of it
being like very small or anything I know
Kevin is still trying to complete it so
I don't think uh I don't think we're
anywhere close to I don't think it's
small anyway I would you know there's so
many similarities with Far Cry 3 in this
I would be very very surprised if for
some reason it's smaller yeah it's
smaller uh so much like like most of the
place it in this game we're going to
have to take the long way around cuz
it's so hilly this game is way more
hilly than uh than Far Cry 3 so many
Hills there's lots of
um lots of wings like the it's it's a
good thing they just give you the wings
suit right off the bat or like pretty
close to the start I guess um cuz I
don't have it yet but um that's pretty
good because you are in need of it a lot
I just did exactly what you did I'm so
sorry I'll get out here I just drove
straight in I got a I got a sniper rfle
hide hi I'm start picking dudes off I
think they already know over here oh
really yeah God damn
it
reinforcements get away from my ladder I
tried to steal my
car oh there's a heavy guy here all
right we're getting into different
territory here oh I guess I'll just hang
out
here I'll respawn in a
second
shot you your bow oh yeah it's
fun oh what oh that was a little late I
know he's still
alive screw this grenade is there a
rocket in there yeah I do eat
it oh smart this guy's smart oh [__] did
I do it again all right we may be
attacking people who are outside of my
uh my ability range so maybe we should
do a story
mission
don't you die on
me H these guys have uh again this is
exactly about Far Cry 3 was bad this
these guys have uh um armor on them yeah
which means you have to oh it's head
shot you can shoot off their helmet I
tried is that a bear well not anymore
not anymore not anymore there's no
be okay where are the next missions
oh
yeah it's like I gave up
here or did
I you want me to save you yeah I'm dead
all
right I may end up dying hey what's up
oh that gun's got no ammo let me try
that
again oh so did did Far Cry 3 have all
the same um progression with like
crafting and and all that
you pick up uh well not identical but
it's it's the same mechanics layered
over kind of like different items and
whatnot but yeah like the crafting
system in this is basically you know you
want to sell all you want to sell all
your um skins but maybe keep a couple of
them there because you'll be able to
build something or make something so
that was all very similar as well mhm
all right okay let's let's just see if
we can have you done any story missions
in this in in Co-op yet no do you know
if you can or not I don't know okay so
we should try that
uh what have you done in Co-op uh
because you guys been playing it a bunch
this week for all the all the features
um I helped yeah I helped out uh some in
the office we did a um which was again
really fun it was like that survival so
the the see the green circle there yeah
those are like kind of like mini game
side quests I know there's like a racing
one um these are the supply drops which
were also in Far Cry 3 that right there
was um there's a survival one where I'm
sure there's a bunch of them were you
know you basically protect some
civilians from um beasts like an
onslaught animal is it always an
onslaught of animals yeah and so the one
I did was honey badgers and it was
hilarious it was really it was tough but
it's really fun there's a hostage rescue
one there oh we could do that that'd be
fun so I don't see I don't think there
are like any
story missions for
Co-Op H it's weird the story stuff the
co-op stuff in um
in Far Cry 3 were these kind of
instanced H all right let's unlock this
Bell Tower because then we might get
some more that's a good idea you do that
real quick um we'll see the the the
dudes there might still be a little bit
above my ability level uh but the uh the
co-op stuff in Far Cry 3 was they were
this instanced four player uh character
yeah let me do it again
um specific character missions but they
weren't in the wider world so you could
just walk around they were just like
these four player missions kind of Left
for Dead sty Almost
sure we got the sweet maned
gun Jeremy swears by the co-op he's I'm
not sure if he's put it up yet but he's
working on a feature bed how he says
coop is the way to play Far Cry 4 um and
himself and AR were having a bunch of
fun yeah you and I had a lot of
fun although I got to say if the story
Mission stuff isn't available that kind
of sucks but we should get like Samson
or Jeremy in here if we can to
um figure that one out once and for
all cuz all we have at the moment is
loot chests propaganda posters all the
sort of tertiary stuff that you can
choose to unlock if you
want yeah I'm sure if we hit one of
these towers will uh is that friendly or
not no it's
not
up
all right okay we're at the tower I'm
getting that cool
oh some home boys over
here oh you know we need to do as well
is look at get out of the car you idiot
oh I just shot him through the car that
was amazing
life all right I'm
sniping oh that was a
civilian it wasn't just a civilian it
was an innocent civilian they've done
nothing wrong he was acting pretty
innocent there's a civilian sleeping in
here as well whoa I shot a got he lit on
fire oh there's a there's a Karma
Mission happening you got a sniper rifle
you can probably take this guy out we
got to kill this Courier before he
escapes with the military info sniper
rifle how about a grenade launcher just
if you can do it quick he's running
away ah maybe he's maybe maybe it's one
of these higgy pigley roads it's going
to turn again yeah it is all right oh is
it
yeah get
down oh I just missed him again all
right does it turn again please turn
again yes it does all right just keep
running keep running keep coming oh good
shot oh oh oh I knocked him out did you
yeah look at I he's uh his his oh man
what a shot
sick I knocked his um car out of order
all right I am running down on him
there's a bunch of like
random like people helping us out as
well die
Courier
cool great oh get the documents I love
how you get karma for this for hunting
down somebody and murdering them I got
Karma what a
guy better fix this car I'll drive back
up to
you we go up and try and clear that
tower out oh there's a question mark on
our our map over there this guy's
getting attacked by an eagle do you know
want to see
oh oh they got him e nicely done skin
skin
it sweet yo Aaron Samson get in
here my man Aaron Samson how's it going
player of Far Cry how you doing my
friend good just talking to your chest
uh yeah do it what's so what's the story
how much Co-op stuff are you able to
actually do can you any story do you
guys want to do like some epic Wing
suiting uh I don't have them unlock Epic
Co-op Wing suiting where bets are they
uh go to the top of the map yeah right
about there somewhere in there you guys
go up there to like where one of the
towers are you can hit North was it kyat
yeah and you do epic Wing suiting or you
guys can go hit the Delta grab some
elephants and beat some crocodiles to
death that sounds great where's that uh
if you go to go to like the waterway in
the middle down here yeah option three
is you guys hit one of the big
forts yeah so I haven't got the
progression to get there yet so what I'm
wondering is can you hit the story beats
while we're uh so like the this guy here
yeah those those those are tough when
who has an RPG you can shoot the
helicopters down is even at this stage
you think we'll be able to no I mean you
can do anything in South kyat right now
you just can't get to the northern part
it'll it'll Auto kill you if you try and
go all the way North so what about all
those missions all those
um uh story stuff like the objective
stuff you're if you're not seeing the
letters on the map with the people's
names you can't do it but you can do all
the side missions together okay cool so
I guess stuff must be locked at for for
Co-Op then cuz I had a bunch of them
before we start Rob is rocking the hot
pink sniper rifle yeah that's your bad
boy that's your bad boy that is uh all
right don't try and take this one out
varka what's going on Rob we're getting
we're hold on I'm getting attacked by a
a dog now here's what you should do when
one person's driving yeah the other
person instead of getting in should
stand on the hood of the car oh really
cuz one it's pimp and two you can use
your main weapon and also flip the bird
and you won't fall off nope how do you
flip the bird uh down on the d-pad oh
really yeah oh yeah we didn't do we
didn't do any of that last time all
right cool uh all right let's doit varka
shot we should try and hit one of our um
nice is that just you can just do that
whenever you want yeah we should have
done that oh it's a real one as well
it's not it's knu Knuckles up yeah it's
it's no wimp flip
bird okay cool go to that bridge right
there I think that's where the
alligators were go down down down down
down left left left right there yeah
right there I have not seen an alligator
yet that would be fun uh okay where's
the where are the places to uh um fix
our I guess we need to get new
guns we got to go any any Outpost you've
already taken you can fast travel to so
where's the nearest
one probably be back this
way way
point fast travel to this one which is
the and then the gyrocopters at the
other one if you go back out a little
bit so that second base has the
gyrocopter left and down yeah right
there can you there yeah that one has a
gyrocopter so then you can get to the
base fast all right let's do that
awesome thanks dude you guys been doing
some gyrocopter we need some direction
uh is the is the thing so grab the grab
your guns the gyrocopter and then yeah
head up to that like crazy base perfect
hou heavy base taken thank you Aaron Sam
thank you appreciate it oh yeah all
right you want to uh trap some weapons
here yes
absolutely unlocked a couple more oh um
buy a wing suit if you can ooh I wonder
if I
can
25k done thank you good
call get some healing syringes get some
body
armor
um this one looks kind of R
actually I'll stay with the
Scorpion and pick
up as much as I love the rocket although
we Aron did say to take out the Choppers
I might hold on yeah I got a grenade
launcher oh yeah that's probably a
better sh that's your secondary as well
that's well that's why yeah that's my um
sidearm I'm going to customize this bad
boy to be honest aon's got a pretty good
setup I don't even know if I want to
switch it up I'll probably go with an
automatic man so much Amo to buy so
expensive all
right blocking that door so I'm hey
thank you for letting us raid your weird
ammunition Closet in your house you have
for some reason thank you come
again oh yeah there's a gyro up here you
want to fly yeah you can sing right of
the Valkyries while we're doing it
so something I haven't haven't done yet
is uh with the bow you can do explosive
arrows or fire arrows oh
yeah fire
arrow and explosive
Arrow I want shoot something with
it sweet all right get in here before
this whole town blows up oh no do you
want me to
descend um yeah I'll just get on the
back the Rope makes me dizzy oh fire
those fire got real real quickly yeah
these [__] came into our village
took all all our weapons and um set it
on fire set the entire Village on fire
don't use all your hours though bro fair
enough how many do you
have uh seven did it say seven or 60
pull back pull back on
it me
switch on the 60 you've got quite a lot
I had like when I started out they were
giving you like seven yeah like seven or
something
yeah it's way
better I was joking when I said good
duh that
dude all right what do you think the
chance of success on this is are we
storming the oh we are like um so Jeremy
and I did one it took us like the third
try to successfully do it do it oh the
coolest was there's a like there's like
a hidden path you can take on to get to
the top of it and we like repel down
stealth like in the middle of it and
this one here yeah well it could be this
one but it was really awesome and they
didn't see us coming we
actually um successfully killed them all
doing that doing that way maybe it's the
same one I could show you we should try
to be stealth but more than anything
else we should disable those alarms yes
exactly which is the same mechanic from
Far Cry 3 as well where you go up to one
of those
um uh alarm triggers and just rip it us
under and it disables their ability to
call in reinforcements right and that's
uh that's where it gets
tricky and you know where these things
are it's the smoke Rising is the like
the sign of the Outpost and I guess the
Fortress as well right we didn't get
that one Outpost so I'm really not sure
how this Fortress thing is going to go
but give it our best shot um I don't
want to get too much quicker to uhoh
don't worry about those guys they're
we're not near the Fortress
yet still on our 300
M so if there's like a cliff top we can
kind of get yeah so it was if we're
heading on it oh wait see I think this
is it that's it oh no this isn't the one
I haven't done this one
okay so let's park our asses up here in
this
tree
all right and stealth our way in we have
actually yet to do that successfully
yeah I don't really have any stealth
things I've got three throwing knives
and meat so I luckily have a bunch of
stealth stuff fortresses there are
heavily guarded outposts more troops
tougher defenses invite a friend and
Co-op to take down a fortress together
good idea or use guns for hire tokens oh
yeah so the guns for high tokens I can't
remember if that was in frer here or not
but you can basically just call in
people uh using is the d-pad you press
down and it calls in a bunch of uh oh
wait hold on um extra folks that'll come
help you out one
second
Fu thanks cool let's do
this H it calls in a bunch of extra
people which will
not take away your cover they will
invade the place without um without
alert in the guards to your presence
which is pretty good yeah okay so let's
let's first off let's spot all these
dudes I always like doing that this is
so it's like this game is basically Far
Cry 3 it's so ridiculous I guess this is
no bad thing did they have any animals
in here there's a gyro copter in there
oh really yeah else we got I've only got
one dude I can't see anyone else I got D
there's a heavy guy in the middle
there's a uh sniper on the right there
he
is probably one over there dude in the
building directly in
front so we could throw down a piece of
meat and distract him right now there's
a doggy right there oh what's is there
see the dog oh right in front of us
weird cute okay all right I'm going
throw throw in a piece of meat all right
do it how much meat do you have I got
one oh sugar I've got zero that's a one
piece of meat
H
what animals just spawn out of
absolutely nowhere when this happens dog
dog's seen something the dog thinks he
can take it or is he going to eat the
meat damn
it we need to kill that dog skin the dog
and then use the dog's meat
us okay oh here's another guy at the
left o I'm jumping in I'm jumping in all
right should I engage h no we need to
stealth this bad boy oh you really want
to stealth it yeah do you want me to
stay up here and snipe while you go
around knifing people yeah all right
keep keep keep I feel like just keep
sketch on what's going on for me there's
good advantage of just hanging out here
and sniping there's another heavy in
here so the problem I'm going to have
with the Heavies is if this is like Far
Cry 3 I won't have unlocked the ability
to melee these guys properly mhm uh
which was uh one of the more important
unlocks in Far 3 so uh you probably have
so I'd probably get down here as well
actually okay so I think upon seeing
that loading of the Fortress we got a
lot more guys now oh really yeah a lot
of guys just popped up they all just
kind of popped up great all right if you
can get down here all
right and make as much noise as possible
smooth the problem those dog we need to
kill that dog relatively sharpish as
well because those guys will will uh oh
where' the heavy
move he's there he's in the middle so oh
there's two Heavies there there's one in
that there was one inside of that room
last time damn oh there he is so there's
a guy here I can get him all
right I'll get him I'll get him with a
bow that's silent uh if you can melee
him that'll be better right now look at
him he's he's looking at something go go
go is he regular
dude should I move his body yeah
H forgot you could do that actually move
it outside no one goes out
here are these arrows they're extra
arrows
all
right okay I was about to shoot that
fire but I forgot I wasn't playing
shadow of
mortar okay heavy here I feel like we
should just kind of loop
around once we take out one of these
middle dudes they'll all know uh so we
can also throw rocks which will oh yeah
throw a W uh throw a rock what if we
threw a rock in right in front of this
do it okay that's a right Dad right
pretty sure try it I think so
yeah he heard you did he yeah he totally
did can you loop around and get uh I
don't think I can kill him cuz he's a
heavy I'll throw another rock closer
here and you can Loop he'll just we'll
kind of just lur him around so you
should probably come around then oh he's
totally doing it sick so you should
probably come around then because I
can't kill him you can't sneak around
from like the other side go go go go
around go around I can't kill him I
haven't got unlocked the melee thing you
oh cuz he's heavy yes
so oh don't
run oh you haven't either
then I
didn't just finish him off on the way oh
my god oh I might take this that kind of
scared me for a second he wasn't going
down cool that worked out uh okay so
maybe what the next thing we should
definitely
do is was there one right there yeah so
maybe the next thing we should do is
take out the alarm Okay so the alarm so
there's an alarm right here oh [__] it's
guy right
there
okay where was the alarm switch right
there I'm throw I'm going to throw a
rock really far don't don't don't don't
they're not looking at oh yeah you're
good yeah all right so we got two more
alarms to take out
before and I think one of them is right
in the middle of the base keep moving
dude I can't pick up his body lame sorry
yeah we get through this it'll be a
miracle
what are you trying to say here I think
there's one alarm in the Middle where
that dude is it's that dog I don't like
at
all should have saved that piece of meat
huh saved it I should have I should have
collected more them I totally forgot oh
that guy's right
there all right what's next want to go
in the middle walk around the periphery
and just kind of get them one by one
well when this guy loops around right
here we could um kill him and I don't
think anyone would see us sniper looking
away different direction you know what I
mean yeah I think it's worth it I just
all right if you want to go for it I'm
going to stare on the outside I wonder
if you dog is on patrol you want to kill
him with a
crossbow uhoh uhoh uhoh oh that was real
close no he's just digging like a
dog [__]
uhoh I might be in no man's land here is
that guy going to look at me every
time
I'm going do
it I'm I'm going to wait behind here and
then I'll have a better
start what just I probably found the
worst possible place to
hide I screw this I'm I'm not going to
melee him I'm just going to get a head
shot oh [__] that dog's coming for me
uhoh uhoh uh oh just kill it need
help I'm gonna hide here I'm gonna hide
here all right when this guy gets so if
he's a heavy you're not GNA be able to
kill him with a crossbow oh you [__]
so you just go up and stab the crap on
like you did last time okay or or or
back out back out hit hit the crafting
hit the abilities thing progress skills
and if you can get in there and just get
the
melee it' be for Tiger right just learn
while you're here yeah I don't
know do you have it press R3 to perform
a take down heavy gunners and Flame unit
have you unlocked
it okay unlock it we're in the mission
so unlock yeah get out out these These
are required I this bullet sponge I have
to have three more okay get out then
back out cuz we're still I don't think
the getes when we do that we're dead all
right so how many ability points do you
need to get three more I have to get
three more which is not even close least
you're a bullet sponge now yeah that's
good news I will um next time he comes
around I'm going to melee the jump up
there and stb the crap at him okay
there's a guy coming towards
me I'm going to go beside you we can
both run up there what what's the uh
like lightning icon mean I'm right
beside you uh I think they are the guys
you want to stop going through the alarm
or something okay here I go care okay
careful if that worked it didn't sniper
sniper where is that sniper all
right reinforcements coming [__] all
right did you just set everything on
fire that was a good call actually if we
if we like go back to where we were go
back to in that there that building we
were if we just like yeah if we hold out
here and just wait for them to come
around one by one we can murder them
it's like tower
defense is explosive Arrow yep dog's
coming oh doggy stab you sorry
Pooch all right this may be this may
actually work oh that guy's got a
Molotov [__] don't throw it
flamer he set himself on
fire
[__] that a helicopter uhoh you've got
the grenade launcher right I do oh hold
on I'm getting is a sniper over here if
you can hold on I'm not doing too
hot
[__]
all right get back get back here can you
take out this s there's a dude
there H so back up back up and go down
the other lane and take out the sniper I
got this
helicopter it's not shooting us take out
the sniper I got a helicopter Rob turn
the [__] around and take out that sniper
please all right hold on we're stuck all
right there you go down there down that
lane okay he's moving now I don't see
him so we're stuck all
right
we're fine another
helicopter oh he's done it's a good
thing this guy can just keep bandaging
his arm up over and over again and live
forever damn head shot is that
helicopter down yet is there another one
I think there's there's another one damn
I I I can get from
here we can take our gyro up and you can
that's a good
point
uhoh [__] I'm jumping down
again okay this guy's heavy assault
rifle I think he left here okay I didn't
mean to get up
here can I pick it up
no we're doing okay we've managed to
clear out quite a lot of these dudes oh
there's a guy oh right there right there
guy right behind him
too did they come to down off the
chopper probably yeah but it's it's a
fite amount oh [__] you down no yeah I
am [__] I can I can walk I can walk ins
inside that uh Hut get me good call [__]
there's a guy
[__] I'm stuck [__] sniper's going to
get me come on move move damn
it what
happened got
iced almost had it almost had
it
that first stealth that last stealth kod
that didn't work out it should have it
was close which was no one shouldn't
have you went up and [__] meleed him
over and over again no one was looking
we don't have it unlocked I think he
yelled I think he screamed like a little
girl I'm surprised we got away with the
first one if I'm being completely honest
all right well we know what to do here
unfortunately the game has managed to
spawn me with the heavy assault rifle so
I say we just don't bother with the
first M I kill and we just go [__]
shoot everyone okay I can do that
because in all that time we killed one
person oh yeah good call just stay up
there and start popping people you got
it oh no one even saw that cool we we're
still uh still stealthy stopy yeah
they're really going to see it when I
knife this
guy oh they didn't I just knifed them
and he
died take out that dog it's annoying
me shut
up my
dog heav down in the middle
nice uh eat monov I guess oh they're
already on fire yeah I kind of did that
nice
work he's
screaming we're doing good
oh
oh damn
it everything's on fire sniper to the
left stabby stabby oh [__] no I'm on
fire what do I do still building on fire
keep hitting keep hitting the
fire uhoh is there a helicopter now yeah
I'm not sure how much we're supposed to
oh wow that guy D loaded I'm on fire as
well I'm on fire is this whole yeah just
put it out like you would heal is this
whole Hut on
fire uh no
anymore oh I got it
now reload
Joe take out this nice oh that was sick
nice was that with the grenade launcher
yeah oh [__] where's this other sniper
oh no he climbed up he climbed up okay
they don't spawn m mission I don't think
nice got him just it's
about damn it all right so what do we
got how many grenades you got
left [__] uh am my
launcher oh no what's going on oh no
helicopter I'm down in the back down all
right gotcha yeah how many grenades you
got in the
launcher uh four cool all right hold on
to those bad boys don't use them against
people I'm on
fire all right they're they're swarming
we got we clean up work here they're
they're swarming
us are they on the roof again they're on
the roof are they on the roof yeah oh
man I'm on fire again what's I got to
throw another Molotov on that
roof h they down again oh [__] building
has been on fire so many times the
structural Integrity of these buildings
is really impressive [__] all right I'm
got to get up there with this heavy
rifle and just try and he does it
there's a helicopter to your right I can
hopefully take out is it really close
the Chopper's pretty
got the helicopter nice did you shoot it
y oh I felt really good for a second I
thought I Tak it out with my heavy H
okay I need to get it I'm going to jump
over here there's a guy on the roof are
you there oh no you're where' you go I'm
running over by the sniper I'm going to
see if I can get his
rifle oh what what's going
on where'd you go there's a guy on the
roof I'm where we were if you if you
just did you just kill yourself no I
didn't kill myself I just they beat me
me up oh okay just um hang there I can
spawn in 15
gotcha
damn it's kind of cool having the
ability to you know cuz you can get
overwhelmed pretty easily in this so
having the ability to have somebody else
be your kind of like respawn point is
right sweet little bit handy you back
action excellent all right and I'm
pissed oh there's a guy coming up
here never mind H I I don't want to me
pick up the sniper rifle this may be an
unlock thing again suck grenade
[__] oh there's a s oh [__] there's a
a chopper you need to take out
immediately if you can I'm dead that's
far get down get down get down get down
get down get down get down oh [__] if I
fall down I'm dead damn
it [__] wish I had some better weapons
it's pretty hard to take these guys out
with a heavy and a
scorpion H all right this time let's
stay back I'll that was working camer
all the guys and you need to kill more
people with the sniper from the top
before coming down before the and then
when the helicopter arrives you need to
get off this Cliff but stay up here okay
and let's just get everyone first Siler
you should try out alarms we should oh
that's a [__] so only three yeah
there's three Josh in the back is saying
there's three alarms you could try and
take out I'm not sure if you can see
them all here I can see one right now
I'll hit him and no just wait up a
second you sure tag all these dudes just
tag and back them you didn't tag many of
them last time well I can take out the
sniper and no one will know so I'm going
do that H tag them before they move if
you
can okay so where are the alarms I know
there's one front of the Hut one in the
middle I can do Recon around the back
and see if I can find the third one but
it's going to leave me super
exposed there's one there right in the
middle with the green light two does
does it say on the map there's
definitely three so there's one
two where's number three I feel like
it's like see the green lights you're
looking for the green lights on top of
those right boxes yeah these things here
see I'm that right one oh on top of the
actual pole so okay unless it's over
oh see this that's I think that's it way
way to the left by that flag I think in
the back right okay
um do you want me to go around in the
back and see if I can get that
I that's that'd be the one to get for
you I I could like snipe this one in the
middle and then I could
um just bolt take out some people and
then just bolt for this one um get in
the Hut and just cuz you yeah I I can
totally do that so I can snipe this one
in the middle and if you got I can take
this one out I think oh you're already
there oh [__]
detected sniper saw you I think sniper
saw
me well that's idea
over all right let's try this bad boy
again if we survive this time H yeah
just snipe those guys as quickly as
possible right now before the CH before
the chopper gets here um if it if if and
when this doesn't work out we can try
that tactic now I'm going to run across
the base and try and spread these guys
out a
bit
[__] you
dog right
two I hate these Molotov guys so much
call me call out guys who are like
really making you it's all right I'm I'm
having a pretty easy time actually at
the
moment all right might want to get out
there now because the chopper is on the
way so get the hell off that now right
now yeah go go
go I can't help you if you die there so
you need to
just there it is I think I can get from
here
damn
no [__] way I meleed you
first oh whatever all right stay alive
all right dude get off the get off did
you kill the sniper the chopper how do
you get down without hurting yourself
jump
down whatever that was a bad start if I
jump down I I hurt myself and I'm
already [__] up you jumped down on the
roof and then jump down again we're not
very good co-op Partners I'm like dude
get off the [__] roof so the SN so
the chopper can't hurt you you're like
no I'll just I'll just keep shooting
them all right Josh's tactic I think is
the winner we just need to not get
spotted up here so I'm going to bank
around the left immediately you start
tagging those dudes okay do it and then
we don't need to take anyone out until
we've actually done it so don't take out
that
sniper
yep and just tag him no no no so tag him
with the camera so I can see them so I
so I can see movement can you tag him
with the sniper rifle as well yeah
sweet get that dog if he's I'm I'm
moving on the
left where's the
pooch can't see
him all right I got
him oh there he
is
okay [__] is that far alarm in the
compound yeah they're all inside the
compound that one is just it's stuck in
the corner this guy's just facing the
wall okay this guy's here so keep an eye
on on the guy beside me there may be a
scenario in which you're going to have
to hit him because I can't okay so he's
currently looks like he's fixing
something can I do Death from Above yet
actually I wonder if I can if you climb
that roof they'll see you
okay so the the heav is coming around I
don't know if he can see you right now I
just unlocked Death from Above oh that
dog eyes on that dog eyes on that dog he
might see me let me take him um I'll let
you
know I think we're okay will they
definitely see me if I get on that roof
yeah they will they'll see you dude
there's like this middle all
right [__]
me that'll solve a lot of my problems if
I can oh you're good now the middle
heavy won't see you oh there's no one on
this
side okay
oo okay so you do have a sniper ahead of
you around that
okay this is
audacious see this anyone around
here so do do they run for the alarm is
that what happens yeah okay so if they
see you they run for those
alarms um doggy is it's like he's six s
oh cool I can spot this sniper there you
go
I wonder if there's a way of me getting
up I wonder if there a grapple over here
or something cuz like the pole is right
there oh that sniper's facing there can
I get up here maybe no whoa whoa whoa
whoa someone's
arriving Enemy enemy convoys are
arriving that's so that's for a
different that's Pagan's B that's like a
side quest thing we're just in the area
at the moment
um all right I'm going to jump back down
again there's no way around this
uh this little bit
well if you yeah if you
like I got to keep scooching so there's
a
dog and then there's the heavy guy if
you went now I'm already past see where
I am yeah you're good if you keep going
I don't think any will see you so check
up on the left further up on the left in
between these two buildings I guess you
probably can't see anything I can't see
anything else there's probably a guy in
that there's a dude in that
building I'm going to tag him so we know
where he moves so there there is a guy
looping around behind you
he's he's pretty far back is he yeah oh
[__] [__] did he see me yeah all right
I'm might as well try to take out the
alarms okay try and take out the alarms
try and take out this
one I got it I got
one if this [__]
works did you shoot the third one
yep yeah did we get all the arms
disabled oh my God how did that work
sick oh sniped Jesus Christ nice work
I'm going to cauterize this wound real
quick okay let's not die I'm going to
take it easy I'm going to try and get
over to
you [__] I have no ammo [__] the snipers
are killing me [__] get the [__]
down uh okay I'm going to try and get
over to you because I don't think
there's a scenario in which both of us
don't die for the whole thing so I need
to be able to get over to like respawn
safety with
you
oh my God the
tension people keep running down the
stairs on fire I'm going to take their
guns oh sniper rifle I'm doing
fine I've got a sniper
too they they're freaking
out I'm using the molotov to like set up
a base of like a gap so they can't come
near me okay here they are
how do you zoom with the sniper it
depends on your [__]
rifle how do you zoom on your sniper I
don't Zoom oh you don't
[__] ooh that was a good
shot oh I'm getting him tag him bag
him this guy is
underground where's that guy gone like
there a guy under what is he doing stick
your head out stupid Bell
Hider I think he's running towards where
me oh he's behind you behind you behind
you oh what he's no where is he he was
right behind you okay stay
there okay stay
there you whoa whoa did you did he kill
you did he kill you yeah
okay okay just keep keep an eye out for
stuff around me just don't move don't
move let me Spawn yeah just keep keep
looking around and see if dude no dude I
didn't see him it was a glitch no no no
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
n just watch behind me oh I know that
I'm watching forward watch that way all
right I'm alive okay
cool back in the game he's throwing a
Molotov up or a grenade
careful dude it's it's dude it was
glitching out for me man he was like he
was like moving he was underground oh
yeah and then he like when I saw you he
like flew across the map and was
somewhere else I did not see him on that
happened when uh uh we did the hunting
as well um you
we were you were killing that that
taurise and you were like what are you
doing I'm like hitting nothing like I'm
killing this taurise and that's weird
cuz in that one I was Lo and that was in
that one I was uh logged into your game
so it wasn't exactly like a client side
error yeah but [__] it we got this sweet
varash six time the charm thanks to Josh
for giving us some sweet tactics we
would not have used should have shot
those alarms a while ago that's pretty
good I love how it like all went wrong
but we just sprinted and turned them off
anyway that's pretty good that was fun
Far Cry 4 is pretty good um sorry it
took so long for us to figure out that
you couldn't do all the story stuff on
what to do um but such is the the nature
of playing these games early as we have
uh that's uh that's as much we've as
we've unlocked so far like I'm now I
guess like three and a half hours in now
and there's all this nonsense still to
get into so yeah yeah Far Cry 4 that's
it yeah we've got a bunch of features up
on the site um review incoming as well I
believe uh gspot.com but for the
meantime for the moment thank you very
much for hanging out thank you so much
Far Cry